Did you write down the truth values for
these two formulas, David?
>> I did.
And on the one on the left,
we find it's little bit easier
because it starts with A and,
which means anytime A is false, we can
go ahead and write that this is false.
When A is true, that means we can ignore
it and evaluate solely based on B or C.
Whenever either of them is true,
the result is true.
And only when both of them are false,
is the result false.
So the one on the right is a little
bit more complicated because for
each of them we need to look
at both A and B and A and C.
But because there's an or in the middle,
that means that once we discover that
one of them is true, we don't need
to really worry about the other one.
A and B is true whenever both A and
B are true, and so A and
B are true here and here, meaning we can
go ahead and say that those are true.
We don't need to look at A and C here.
Similarly, A and C are true here.
So we can go ahead and
say that this one is true as well.
For all the ones at the bottom,
A is false which means it's going to
go ahead and render both of them false.
And for the fourth one,
B and C are both false,
meaning each individually
is going to become false.
So what we see here is that the truth
values for these two formulas actually
end up the same, so
I guess they're equivalent as well.
>> Good, David.
So this property's called
the distributive property.
The distributive property says that
these two formulas have
the same truth values.
And in particular, if there is B and
C inside the parentheses with
a disjunction between them, and
A is outside the parentheses
with a conjunction between them,
then we can move A inside
the parentheses by first writing A and
B and then writing A and C and
taking the disjunction of the two.
>> We can also think of this as
distributing the part outside
of both the predicate and the operator
into both the ones on the inside.
We take the A and
apply it to B, so A and B.
apply it to C, so A and C.
And we preserve the operator
in between B and
C in between the two new parenthesis.
So if this had been A or B or C,
this would become A or B, or B or C.
This would become A and B and C and
would be all the operators here.